what's up everybody welcome back to
another episode of
directors react stunt people react the
effects artists react when neither of
those things
I mean this might be this might be a
stunt men react we'll find out
[Music]
oh damn
anyways uh I'm here with Danny and
Michael uh from rackaracka
I've been wanting to get these guys here
for years and they're finally here in
the USA because they made a movie and
it's going to be a wide release movie in
America a24 picked it up I'm holding
hype on the tips of my fingers there
will be violence let's go let's get into
it man
ladies and gentlemen I present to you
it is
[Applause]
so complacent and happy ruling is so
easy
My Moment no turning back
[Applause]
so with the wrestling stuff there is no
chance for takes or like proper setups
for like proper stunt stuff I mean
they've got the mat on the floor but the
style of wrestling Marco does is like
hardcore Deathmatch wrestling where the
point of it is yes yes it's insane so it
takes it to another element of risk and
danger you get so much more of an
appreciation from the fans I think
because death match wrestling is like
going extra mile and like you know
risking so much more you know physically
than than standard wrestling which is
already risky it's like really extreme
performance art where it's like the
body's the canvas and the blood's the
paint but yeah so you like it it's
different from a film like you don't use
fake barbed wire you don't use fake
glass or fake blood or or fake thumbs
out like it's all real I'm surprised you
managed to keep going can you tell when
somebody's actually like doing like I'm
actually hurt versus like oh I'm faking
her can you tell is there a subtle
difference there no I guess it'd be for
the viewer for me it's like I just
remember being in a lot of pain like
that's a Ronald face like a crazy world
that's like
every time that I wanted to scream I
remember I had to do it in that voice
scream I'd have to do it in there that
pitch
this is insane this is insane this drop
right here okay so you're lying there
and there's a dude like you know a story
above you 10 feet above you and he jumps
do you tense up yeah so you so you're
supposed to stay like loose and then
right on
it's tense up just
just and you and you go you bring your
arms up a little bit so like there's
like a force stopping it instead of just
like onto nothing you know right at the
last second you'll see me like I'm see
I'm there and then right at the last
second I so you have to be really
accurate with your timing your aim all
that kind of stuff yeah and I thought he
was going to give me more time because
when he I thought he was gonna like
really you know act up to the crowd yeah
and he just went and then I was like
I'll sit up there like man he's high
like oh he's coming
so how do you signal like you're trying
to play hurt right and you are a little
hurt too how do you also signal keep
going sorry that that will come in and
whisper something to you you're good
man I don't want to ruin wrestling trade
I'm not a wrestler at all but like
they'd come up and before they do
something to you are you good or tell
you what the next move is so then we did
another event back a backyard event
called racquet vs wrecker well we just
wrestled in the backyard
you just go yeah Marcus goes it's really
rough with me actually you want to
wrestle
oh yeah oh man yeah Jesus yeah it's this
weird addiction like I thought so like
it's exhilarating exhilarating
adrenaline rush for some reason and the
most painful part of this match was not
about why it was that for some reason
yeah that homie that was the only thing
I remembered like hurting
[Applause]
this next part's very mean I was like
like pretending to be hurt I don't know
what is he doing
damn
but I knew you wasn't
I now we can talk about professional
stunts uh yeah wow you don't use any of
this look this is this is the birth of
the artists right this is we're doing
the origin of these directors these
Visionary filmmakers this is where you
guys came from well it was like I gotta
tell the whole story yeah
is yeah we had like 12 to 15 kids around
the same age and we'd all get together
make movies and wrestle like the
wrestling was one side of it and the
movie making was another side of it but
like the resting thing was getting
dangerous because me and Michael kept
trying to top each other it was our
friend's older sister Nelly she was the
one that veered us towards the
filmmaking site as opposed to the
wrestling side yeah she's like I want
scripts I want to I want to see this I
want to see this and so we veered away
from like just hurting each other for no
reason to actually like perfect in the
craft of filmmaking
you wish is one of these videos that I
first saw your kind of stuff I remember
like Freddy was watching I was like holy
[__] you guys should check this out
they're watching this like damn these
guys know how to shoot action right
right yes that's about the shooting in
the VFX because it's pretty [__] we've
got to admit no that's pretty rad
here's the thing like people constantly
were saying that like the VFX on our
YouTube channel are better than movies
and it's not true the VFX movies are
better than the vehicle
well it's more because when you're doing
it on YouTube like you have all this
planning and like it's going to take you
hours to do that shot so you're gonna
make it a special shot and so the shot
itself regardless of the VFX is just a
special shot it's a big moment right
whereas movies and visual effects all
the time whether it's a big moaner not a
big moment so emotionally our shots felt
like they were better shots because they
had more emotional impact not because of
visual effects but because we would only
spend our VFX cards on Big Shots you
guys are the same way where like when
you guys are doing visual effects
they're moments they feel better than
movie visual effects in a lot of ways
because you guys are like going like I
need to hit somebody with something like
that literally hit some
emotionally hit somebody with something
I'm gonna get this effect to do that and
like it serves that purpose so it's like
it's triggering that response
I know that another thing that helps as
well is that like once everything's set
more professionally it's less impressive
or something so I know that like I would
always shoot my way of like it looks
homemade it looks homegrown and that's
why when the big moments happen on like
a smaller scale thing it's like what the
[__] where'd that come from yeah it just
hits people differently you know the big
movies and they've got hundreds of
millions of dollars it's like yeah but
that could be a fact
as soon as Michael runs through an
action even when Michael starts moving
or anyone starts moving and I'm shooting
I I just I feel it out and like give
everything more life it's like you know
what I think style came from like we had
to hide so much stuff because you know
we had no resources so it was like
hiding action and stuff with movement
and Sound and Music to like make it look
way more intense than it is you know so
I think that's where the style came from
your special effects are really good
[Music]
Crazy Wire can you guys shot us about
like two days yeah
it's insane yeah yeah are you guys
painting the cranes out yeah yeah we
always do things like Transit as
practically as possible so all this is
all actual wire work with actual cranes
like this is like big stunt work you
guys I said yeah we ever made on YouTube
we put it back into the videos like
that's all constantly broke
although I remember there's always
YouTube comments saying
I'm
sorry I haven't talked about it ages ago
like it was going to be a big collab
whatever it was but will you guys live
on the other side of the world yes
[Music]
oh my God here this is how crap we are
at editing and how like this is because
it's just a lot of me and Michael like
for like the edits and stuff this always
makes me cringe at this video and me
pointing this out now it'll ruin the
video for for you as well oh God all
right so I I do the color grade and like
I'm editing and stuff and then like
we're about to put it out I wanted to
change something about the grade so I
changed it and then when I put it back
in I accidentally moved the city bars at
the top it's like it's so small
crazy
I said remove it and it's like it's
going viral like no
[Music]
so we shot these back to back we shot
hell of us Call of Duty Marvel vs DC and
Walking Dead versus Last of Us all back
to the same set in the same set and we
just redressed it with everyone and
there's a screen Australia that were
like a local government funding body and
they're amazing they were really
supportive for us and like we were able
to like grow this is our first time
really managing a real crew and like
this so we had a production designer we
had like stunts properly for the first
time as well so we were able to like
really like learn more and like like
another step towards us making a film I
wanted to go back to perfecting what I
was doing before this stuff which was
the earlier childhood stuff which was
writing and characters and stories like
there was never that in the rack of
videos and so like there was always
something missing creatively for me with
the YouTube stuff like I was always
scared to try and put in like a
character or a storyline or anything it
was always like I wanted to go the next
level or whatever it's like that's the
way talk to me was in response to that
light the candle to open the door
and blow it out
so this is a horror movie it's a horror
film everyone was like expecting a
comedy or an action from us and this was
me like being able to really express
myself personally which I never really
did with rakaraka like I was scared of
how the audience would react and so like
this wasn't made of like the rackaracker
audience in mind this was just written
in a way for me to express like how I
was feeling at the time put your hand on
it
usually you're shooting your own stuff
and you're like you know you're
performing in front of the camera here's
a film you're not in front of camera and
you're clearly not shooting it
so what was that like how did you still
make it yours a very in-depth
conversations with all parts of it to
really convey our vision and then
finding someone that we knew we could
trust that we knew was better than us
that was going to teach us things I was
like before I head to departments I
didn't want to look at something and be
like I could have done that like if I
have that sort of feeling then I'm like
that's not a good head of department for
me like when we found our like our key
people it was like it just elevated
things that made our job being able to
focus on stuff that we'd never have time
to focus on before like talking with the
actors and like focusing on characters
and beats and stuff like that like that
stuff gets lost in the rack of stuff but
with the film stuff everyone's working
together yeah and it's like say Aaron
McCluskey our dop he was open to
collaboration we'd spend every day
shortlisting together what about this
you know coming up with a style for the
film he'd show us things that we'd never
seen before like it was just working
really really close with the headset
Department it's way better because you
have these specialists
talk to me
foreign
she lets in a spirit and we like tilt
the camera so initially here we had her
hair start to float like she was
underwater oh really yeah so it was like
waving and the effects team did such an
incredible job but it looked so good but
for me it stood out it felt like a V
effect even though it seriously looked
Flawless it still I'm like it takes me
out of it once it's like a character
film and it's like smaller like already
the moment of her getting possessed is
such a big thing to add like an extra
element on top of it I think was too
Fantastical yeah because then you start
thinking about like oh what's going on
with her hair this is like what's going
on with in her mind yeah yeah yeah big
shout out to kojo Studios our VFX team
there uh they nailed it and I said sorry
dudes sorry dude and I even met the
artist I did it he was like so rare like
before I'd cut it that's terrible I mean
that's that's one of the hard things
about directing man there is a
director's cut that goes for 20 minutes
longer it was tough to cut a lot of
character moments that are really great
but essentially if it doesn't need to be
in the film it doesn't push the story
forward you don't need when you're in
the edit because it's all said uh
subtextually and and just through their
emotions you know so there was a lot of
stuff we could cut like that
oh
[__] is that a puppet 3D really no
really it was real yeah this is our
amazing special effects team that's a an
animatronic but yeah it's puppeteered so
there's like 400 rods all over it and
they're moving it and making it breathe
and everything I was I was actually
there moving its ear everything had a
practical base and it was always the
subtle things that we would add to it
like subtle movements to its face and
then we would even peel back once the
VFX were on so like we initially had
like more blinks and stuff like that and
I was like it looks too weird like even
subtly into the normal eye people might
not think it but when I was looking at
like no something about that looks off
that because it was completely done in
the computer once your movie was picked
up did it change again no no it just
that was amazing about 824 and I think
it's maybe for production as well like
the very filmmaker at first so like they
were never like oh we'll just change
this so we'll cut this down and we'll do
that like they literally took the film
as it is and like I've supported the
vision and like what was presented yeah
there's nothing they haven't asked to
change anything and even like you know
I'd say the movie is
97 how like in my mind 97 what I wanted
to be like it's basically exactly how we
want it which a lot of people don't get
so we actually got that which is amazing
please watch our film talk to me it
comes out July 28th please please
up against Barbie and Oppenheimer
we need all the help we can get oh my
gosh man making a film what are you
gonna make a film we've actually made a
couple but nothing you know nothing
that's on a24 or anything no we've made
a couple but it's all been like
interesting like middle grounds between
YouTube and movies on commitment to like
making a film and trying to get into
theaters it's tough to step away from
the YouTube stuff well it's so
successful like you're like the channel
is like yeah like we we kind of have
this perfect scenario where we have an
audience in like a studio an incredible
team and like we don't get to
necessarily do a one Focus project for a
couple years yeah but on the flip side
we get to do so many different cool
things yeah we never would have had an
audience without YouTube you know we
never would have got the experience we
did or the eyeballs on us that we did if
it wasn't for YouTube so I'm always
thankful to YouTube you know so much of
filmmaking involves a pitch an idea this
and that you're working with people you
show up here and they're with different
projects and then one pops and you keep
that up you keep that up and it's not
until you put in years and years and
meet lots and lots of people that you
really have that connection that Network
now the only way you build that is by
being passionate about it and getting
out there and doing it yeah yeah and
then like even like the more writing it
was never waiting for funding to write
it's like like if I like
to the page even if it's bad like you
know you can start with like oh how do
they do that let's try to do our version
of that like that's what we did as kids
like all copying stuff that we watched
like we were copying evil dead or wall
copying you know lost or Xena when you
were do you love Cena Yeah
do you know this stunt explain this one
right Xena
folks
explaining the physics of this
[Laughter]
your Naruto video yeah
[Music]
wow
I still don't know how they did that
wide shot how do they do that wide shot
you know I bet you they just had her
against the sky just keyed out the blue
like a blue screen just compped her into
that other shot what in the 90s they had
blue screens in the 90s but like yeah
see they shot right here you just take
that and you key out the blue and you
just stick around the shots
yeah
I don't know about that uh Niko
I think she did it for real hey she
might have who knows we just have a wire
dangling there's just
[Music]
so good
it's so ridiculous it's so awesome this
inspired a lot of rakaraka yeah like see
all the face expressions like we like we
always have a thing called the racker
face like we'd always be like
what is that and that's all from Zina
like uh like Xena would always do these
ridiculous faces but they had like
what's like the hardest stunt you can
think of from like just a regular movie
that like you guys think back to all the
time my favorite stump one of my
favorite stunts ever is in Smallville
the pilot
[Applause]
are you kidding me
what come on man now that's a stunt wow
dude how loud is that that's insane I
love that stunt to death God dang that's
like such a gnarly car hit yeah freaking
debris and everything debris Sparks
excuse me land on one of the poles no no
the poles are foam because you can tell
the weight when he kicks it he kicks the
phone like you're not like yeah but like
man that is 10 out of 10 stunt to me
that's incredible yeah you gotta get
this guy on stuck to reactions
leave a comment if you worked on if this
is you please leave a comment leave a
comment yeah and I know what he was
thinking I've got a backpack on
that's padding enough when we got into
Corridor I think about the fact that
like in the industry there's people that
are shooting every day and like I'm
trying to get to their level and every
day that passes that I don't shoot
something in their shooting the Gap is
growing right it doesn't matter if you
guys are shooting it on like a handled
camera or you're shooting in your
backyard you're practicing filmmaking
every single day and you've been doing
it every single day the point now where
you guys have an a24 film we never
looked at like oh this is getting all
things like that 24 7 is all we think
about is filmmaking right and like
scenes and ideas like we can't not do it
it was just um something in us like we
always just want to be creating we can't
help it we're always just making
something and as we've just been like
that ever since we first picked up a
camera because even even like at like
eight years old before we'd even filmed
we were making movie covers like drawing
them up and stuff like we had all that
stuff but we were just like Obsessed the
idea of film and like worlds that you
could create that people could escape to
is so incredible it's like
amazing the most beautiful thing ever
enemy rock paper scissors 2 is live
right now on Corridor digital.com click
the link in the description or on the
screen here to go check it out